turning now to Washington Congress is
launching a new effort to crack down on
Tick Tock a dozen Democratic and
Republican senators are co-sponsoring a
bill that would give the government
expanded powers to respond to what they
call a potential national security
threat Ed O'Keefe visit the White House
Ed good morning Vlad good to see you the
legislation which doesn't directly name
Tick-Tock would give the Commerce
Department broader powers to outright
ban or at least restrict Tick-Tock and
other apps tied to China and five other
nations deemed U.S adversaries the new
bipartisan proposal is the first to get
the White House on board it says the
bill would help the federal government
keep apps from exploiting U.S technology
in a way that risks sensitive data or
national security Now tick tocks used by
at least 100 million Americans each
month and because its parent companies
Chinese the concern among Federal
Regulators is the Chinese government
might one day try to use the data
collected by Tick Tock to track users or
use the platform for widespread
propaganda in a statement Tick Tock no
fan of this it says the Banning the app
in the U.S is a ban on the export of
American culture and values to the
billion plus people who use our service
worldwide it says there are other
methods for the bite Administration to
address National Security concerns and
whether all of this will hold up in
court remains uncertain previous
attempts by the Trump Administration for
example the rain in certain apps have
been blocked by federal courts out of
concern it would violate the First
Amendment Tony
all right Ed thank you very much I got
it